want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carl michael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only bruce lipton
[Music]
money is the equivalent of energy so you
can buy energy with your cash and the
significance about that is if you're
frugal and take care of your money and
keep a balance then you always have this
energy in your bank account energy in
which you can live
however obviously if you waste this
energy then you actually interfere with
your own survival so you don't really
want to go out and just throw away your
money and so basically i really want to
show you that this is an important
insight into the nature of our own
health and our biology in the world we
create in this regard that our
biological system the cells rely on
energy without energy there's no life so
fundamentally you have an energy budget
that gives you life and in fact in the
body energies in coins called atp
molecules that represent units of energy
so in fact biologists refer to atp as
the coin of the realm the significance
of atp is this
is that atp molecules are like units of
gasoline like gallon of gas that are
used to fuel our biological processes so
to stay alive we have to have all this
atp so there's an atp account in your
body right now but the question is how
do you use this atp and now here's an
important fact that
25
of the total energy in your whole body
is used to operate your brain so all of
a sudden you start to recognize that the
brain uses energy at the rate of muscles
of a marathon runner so a brain and
muscle activity are pretty much the same
and so why is this important because as
you're using your brain as you're using
your thinking you are actually using
energy now why is this relevant the
answer is very simply this because the
way we've been using our thoughts are
not necessarily productive a matter of
fact sometimes our investments of our
thoughts are actually counterproductive
because our thoughts create a reality
that we then have to overcome so
basically it says that we must start to
become aware of our thoughts and why is
this important because thoughts
represent units of energy every time you
have a thought you use energy why this
becomes relevant is if i give you a
checkbook for your bank account you
don't go down the street and just write
checks to people like oh hey you're a
nice looking guy here's 10 bucks for you
and oh here little girl go out and buy
yourself a little car here's a thousand
dollars for you and you don't give away
your money why because giving away your
money is giving away your life so
basically you become very frugal when
you have a checkbook in your hand
now what i'm trying to tell you is this
you have an energy budget in your body
the energy is what keeps you alive when
you start using energy and writing
checks where you get no return from your
energy then it's exactly the same as
writing checks out of your bank
checkbook and giving away your cash so
why this becomes important is the
biology of belief reveals how our
thoughts create our reality and if you
start investing in thoughts that are
counterproductive thoughts like fear or
what am i going to do and how am i going
to escape this problem or how is this
going to go wrong and all these other
kinds of thoughts that are negative
kinds of thoughts then realize this
you are actually not just using your
energy for having these thoughts but
these thoughts are also what come into
your reality what you focus on with your
thoughts your brain will manifest as
reality i don't care how much knowledge
is in your head if that knowledge
doesn't go into your subconscious your
life will stay exactly the same as it
was you can be the brightest smartest
academic and i say fine did it change
your life and the answer is no
you have to take the knowledge that you
are walking within your conscious mind
and put that knowledge into your
subconscious programming
and when you do that
you are all powerful in the creation of
your own life and so just walking around
and being able to recite all these
wonderful sayings and things that you
hear from all the wonderful teachers
that we have you say oh yes i remember
that that's a good quote that's a nice
quote oh that's a wonderful saying
it's irrelevant
until that saying becomes part of your
program because now you are living from
the saying and not talking about the
saying
and that was the total transformation of
a life that on an academic level was
successful on a personal level i don't
even want to talk about that
but it changed everything why
because instead of having to chase
after life
after this understanding
things came to me the light will bring
it to you the only thing that's in your
way of the light is a block in your
belief that other people have put into
your programming
you take your knowledge that you have
make it your subconscious program and
you will manifest all of the wonderful
spiritual wisdom that you have heard
throughout your whole life is not words
now
it is life and behavior
and that's our destination in 1925
physicists said that our vision of a
universe split into an invisible energy
realm and a material physical realm was
a total illusion that everything is
energy the whole thing there is no
matter in this world and to summarize
what the meaning was a famous physicist
in 1930 by the name of sir james jeans
said we have been led to believe that
the universe is a great machine
when in fact it is more a great thought
and the reality about that was quantum
physicists have established since 1925
that consciousness is the primary
mechanism of creativity of the world
that we experience in fact a more recent
article in the journal nature which is
like a
scientific mainstream journal was an
article by a quantum physicist at johns
hopkins university by the name of
richard conhenry
and his article was entitled the mental
universe
i i know the last two lines in the
article because they were like
so powerful and here's what the
conclusion of the article was
the universe
is immaterial
it's mental
and spiritual
live
and enjoy
and this is so exciting because science
is coming out saying it's mental and
spiritual it's like oh my god but that's
the quantum physics part
and the reality about it why is that and
so important as uh assad vijay had just
mentioned
it's our thoughts
that are manifesting this world now you
could say that's a spiritual thing and
now i say not only is it spiritual now
it is fundamental basic science of the
universe and it says then the thoughts
are creative well if the thoughts are
created then who's having the thought
and you start to realize i'm having the
thought well then the truth is simple as
richard cohn henry said
you are creating this world with your
mental activity and your spirituality
combined and then all of a sudden it
says well then if i'm creating the world
then my original belief that when things
didn't go right i was a victim
the universe wasn't supporting me you
know it's like oh i try so hard and the
universe is not giving me things it
turns 180 degrees around
and it basically says this we
are creating this world
and then i say your mind is creating
this world the cells in your body are
covered up by the skin disconnected from
the environment but in order to survive
these cells have to adjust their
genetics and their behavior to adapt and
maintain their survival in a changing
environment so the question is then how
do the cells inside your body
actually know what's going on in the
real world because they're not connected
to it i go this
is the role of the nervous system the
nervous system's job is to read
environmental signals and then relay
those signals into the cell so as
illustrated right here we are getting
signals from two different environments
in our body signals from within our body
as well as signals from without our body
and the function of the nervous system
is to read both of these environments
the relevance is the nervous system
reads the information in the environment
and then translates it into signals that
are sent to the 50 trillion cells inside
your body to alert them to what is going
on in that world so in fact that is a
true statement the environment is
controlling the behavior of your cells
but the mind does an interpretation of
those signals based on our life
experiences now for a lot of people this
seems difficult but let's put it in a
different context because we can talk
about computers there's a very
interesting fact about our brain as a
computer because it has an auto-correct
mechanism built into the subconscious
meaning what well i can have my
conscious mind like typing on the
computer
about what's going on in the world
but if i type something that signal can
be translated and sent to the cells
but if i type something that the
subconscious has no recognition of it
will do like an autocorrect and change
what i wrote to fit something that it
thinks that i wrote as a subconscious so
i put in
love and subconscious changes that to
live that's a whole different meaning at
this point because of misinterpretation
so the point is
your wishes and desires of your
conscious mind are filtered by the
programs in your subconscious mind and
if you have a wish or desire that
doesn't conform to a program that
already exists then the subconscious
mind's job is to re-translate that into
something that makes sense for the
subconscious belief not for the
conscious
so uh we may have wonderful wishes and
desires
and if it doesn't conform to the
programs that we receive
the subconscious will change those into
something it understands to make sense
of what i just said consider using your
cell phone that you write something in
your cell phone such as let's put the
word epigenetics in the cell phone and i
go
when i type epigenetics in the database
in the phone says i don't know that word
at all and then what does it do it
throws up different options
that could be closely related to
epigenetics and so the significance is
if i put something into my system that
is not supported by the program
then the programming system will change
whatever i did to accommodate what it
believes is right
now the issue about this is well if i
want to have epigenetics in my phone
then what i really have to do
is open up my dictionary and add the
word epigenetics and now after that
anytime i write up a genetics the phone
mechanism will understand what i'm
talking about well going into the
database and changing the program is the
function of what energy psychology is
all about it says if your behavior is
not conforming to your wishes and
desires then it will be necessary to go
into your program and install new
behaviors that you want to manifest so
now the brain will have a reflection or
resource of what you're talking about so
i really want to emphasize the nature of
biology belief is different than the
fact that just environment controls your
genes and i'll give you a very simple
example of what i mean by that but the
fact that i can have two people
in the very exact same environment
but each of these individuals has a
totally different reaction to the
environment
so if it was just environment that
controls your genes and your behavior
then both individuals should have exact
same behavior
but the reality is no
the two people have different responses
to the environment i go why same
environment
but their minds have different
interpretations and it's the
interpretation of the mind about that
environment that is sent to the cells
so the important part is this yes
environment controls epigenetics
there's an external environment
but an internal environment
and that recognized in humans the
internal environment is not a direct
readout from the external world it's an
interpretation
of that external world and that's why
each of us has a different response to
the world in which we live and that is
why the biology of belief is an
extension
of the foundation that environment
controls epigenetics you can change the
programming
you can rewrite your subconscious
programs
and why is that relevant
if you took the wishes and desires of
the conscious mind and use that as a
program to put the beliefs into the
subconscious mind
it's the most exciting and liberating
thing you can ever do in your life you
know why because once it's in the
subconscious program
95 of the day without you even thinking
about it your mind will take you to that
direction
and that is your freedom i was looking
for relationships i kept failing at him
okay
i end up in the caribbean teaching at a
medical school
the universe throws this into my lap the
perfect pickup line in the whole world
is sort of like hey if you're not doing
anything you want to come and stay in my
villa in the caribbean and hang out i
have a villa on the beach and i got my
own place and
and i still wasn't able to find anybody
but i kept looking because i said i
need a relationship i need a
relationship so
i meet this woman who comes off of some
yacht and she's you know i've got a
future that's like she'll do what she
wants and i thought well if you're not
doing anything why don't you uh you want
to come and stay with me in my villa on
this beautiful island
she looked at me and she looked at me
and then she said
i can't be with you
and i sort of like stopped for a moment
and she looked at me and she said you're
too needy
it hit me i said oh my god
what am i looking for a relationship why
because you're not happy so if you're
looking for a relationship because
you're not happy then you're depending
on that relationship to make you happy
so that's not a nice relationship it's
codependency if i give you this place to
stay you will make me happy that's a
trade you know it's like yes
and after she said that i i was stunned
for a moment i can't be with you you're
too needy she said i was
and then all of a sudden i said thank
you thank you very much it was sort of a
slap in the face right a blessing in
disguise right
it totally was it was like wake up and i
walked away from that and i looked at my
life and said you got this most amazing
job you teach a couple days a week you
live in the caribbean you got a villa
you got money in your pocket because you
get paid and there's nothing to buy in
the caribbean anyways you got i say
you're healthy you got money you got a
great place to live you have the most
wonderful job i go you can't be happy
with that that's what i said to myself
i said how can i
you know i'm looking for this person to
make me happy i said oh no first i make
me happy yeah and then when i make me
happy
that change and it did what happened is
i stopped bitching and started to enjoy
look don't you love where you live yeah
i love where i live do you love the sea
oh i love the sea you like it oh i love
my job and all of a sudden i started
focusing on hey these are things i love
i guess what
i didn't need anybody
that's when you created abundance and
that's when people became attracted to
you right a hundred percent because once
i didn't need them i wasn't like yeah
i was like i don't care it's fascinating
how it works then they showed up they
showed up because i did not need that
was the word because need puts pressure
on that other person that they have to
provide
and then they didn't have to provide it
was like hey let me hang out with you i
don't have to provide anything i could
just be me i go yeah you be you i'd be
me we have a great time
and that was the beginning of
reprogramming a need for a relationship
until i was happy with myself
and until that had once i was happy with
myself and i didn't need a relationship
you should have seen how many
opportunities showed up that were never
there in my life before because the need
part pushed them away the science that
says there are two minds that are
operating at the same time one is called
the conscious mind or one is called the
subconscious mind i say what's the
difference
the conscious mind is where you are as a
spirit an entity a unique identity you
are
in that conscious mind and perceiving
the world i say what about the
subconscious mind it's not a creative
mind the subconscious mind is habits
things that you've learned and you
experienced in your life and they become
habits so uh the subconscious mind is
not thinking creating a subconscious
mind push the button
play the behavior
so here's the point when we are in our
conscious mind we are connecting our
spirituality to the biology and the
physical planet that we're in and that
is a creative mind that's the one you
wake up in the morning and say
oh i wish i had this and i desire that
and these are the things i want
and then you go out and start the day
and then guess what
95
of the day
you are not operating from the conscious
mind science has recognized 95 percent
of the day because we are thinking 95
percent of the day our behavior is now
controlled by the subconscious mind
i go okay so what's the difference in
the final conclusion of this is
the conscious mind with your creativity
has your wishes and your desires
the subconscious mind was programmed by
other people
your mother your father your siblings
and your community so what is the
difference
you wake up with a wish and a desire of
what you want
and then the rest of the day
you play the programs that you got from
other people that don't answer your
wishes and don't support your desires
and all you see is the consequence of it
and go oh my god why is it not working
the answer is because you don't see
because remember the name is
subconscious
below conscious
so when that behavior is playing
psychologists will tell us
70 percent or more
of the programs in the subconscious
are disempowering
self-sabotaging and limiting behaviors
so the simple reality is this
we have great wishes and desires and yet
our life is not controlled by that our
life is controlled by the programming
and that programming is the
disempowering program so all you see
is the consequence of the invisible
subconscious which will sabotage
all the desires and wishes you have and
then to conclude that
what if you just didn't
default to the subconscious what if you
just stayed in the conscious mind that's
called being mindful
and why is it relevant
because when you stay
conscious keep your mind present
you are the creator
of your life and when people are in
mindfulness they manifest their wishes
their desires and their happiness so for
all of us it's sort of a wake-up call
you think you're running your life with
your wishes and desires it's an illusion
you're really running your life with
your programs acquired from other people
well how do you change the subconscious
mind say how did it learn in the first
place
i say what was the first one i say theta
seven years brain was functioning lower
vibration than consciousness
you have to slow down the brain to a
much slower vibration then it goes into
the subconscious mind
that's why um hypnotherapists in the old
days they had a watch and they would
swing it back and forth so the watch
would swing and they would tell the
person you're getting sleepy
you're getting tired and the reason they
say that is because that shuts down the
conscious vibration and the next
vibration is theta
which is hypnosis so to get you into
hypnosis first i have to get your
conscious brain to stop
and then
in hypnosis state theta the vibration
theta
then whatever is coming from the outside
is not going into my conscious mind
whatever i see on the outside is going
into my subconscious program so if you
want to change the subconscious you have
to talk to the subconscious and go how
you do that well number one hypnosis
and i go oh what i need to see the
hypnotherapist i go no this is the cool
part
i say why i said we have different
vibrations the lowest vibration is delta
is sleep the next higher vibration is
theta hypnosis imagination the next
higher vibration is alpha calm
consciousness and the next higher
vibration is called beta which is like
school room like what we're doing here
consciousness okay i go so why is it
wrong i said when you're asleep you're
at the lowest and when you start to wake
up you go up first to theta uh and
that's like in the morning where you're
half awake and half asleep and and then
i said but then when you're awake you're
in alpha now you're in consciousness and
then when you go to work you're in beta
which is like the working consciousness
but when you come home it reverses
so i come home from work i'm in beta but
i relax oh the consciousness vibration
slows down the alpha
and here's the fact the moment that the
vibrations get a little lower than alpha
consciousness is now shut off for the
night you're sleeping
yeah but there's a period of time after
alpha shuts off before it reaches delta
the lowest one
there's a period of time of theta
i go why is it relevant i said you put
earphones on
and the moment and you play a program of
what of what you want
a self-help program of have make a
relationship be healthy do a job
whatever you get the program self-help
program i say you put it on on a cd
player let's say and you put the
earphones on and while you're still
awake just before you go to sleep you
can hear what's going on
but the moment you fall asleep
conscious mind shut off but guess what
theta is on the work is getting done
right right you're getting a
self-hypnosis with the earphones so
whatever the you didn't hear it you were
sleeping
the subconscious mind was hearing it and
when you repeat that that's how you put
a new program in so that's number one
self-hypnosis i had tenure i had tenure
at the university i walked out of the
university and said look i i
can't keep my integrity and at the same
time teach something i know was patently
wrong
so i walked out because i saw that
teaching the belief that genes control
life was very very incorrect and
it's very interesting because i did that
in 1970 now that's like 30 uh 40 years
ago
i was cloning stem cells back in 1967
40 years ago
and the significance was while i was
doing this research i was also teaching
medical students so i was teaching
medical students the foundation of how
cells work the conventional story out of
the textbook genes control life what we
call the genetic determinism the belief
that genes control your traits behavior
your physical characteristics etc and
what my research revealed when i was
studying the stem cells was this very
profound i put one stem cell in a petri
dish all by itself and it would divide
every 10 to 12 hours so it'd be 2 4 8 16
cells 32 cells after about two weeks i
have thousands of cells in the petri
dish but what was unique they were all
genetically identical but then i did the
experiment experiment was to take some
cells out of the dish and put them into
a separate dish with a different
environment okay and so the environment
is a culture medium but the culture
medium to cells is like the world that
we live in it's got the air the water
the food all the things in it
so i take the cells out of my stem cell
dish put them in a separate dish with a
different environment and the cells form
muscle
but then i went back to the same dish
with genetically identical cells in it
took some cells out put them in a
different environment and they form bone
and then i went back to the same dish
with genetically identical cells and put
them in a third petri dish with a
different environment and they form fat
cells and there i was confronted with
this reality all the cells are
genetically identical but they had
different fade fat muscle bone i said
simple question what controls the fate
of cells and the answer is the
environment it was the only thing that
was different because they were all
genetically identical so i started to
really say oh my goodness here i am
teaching genes control life
to the medical students and yet the
cells were revealing to me that hey they
all had the same genes but it was the
environment that i put them in and so
the environment controlled their life
and a very simple experiment that is
very profound for us today is
if i took my dish with plastic petri
dish with cells in it and moved it from
a healthy environment to a less than
healthy environment the cells get sick
and if i were a doctor of cells i you
might say well what kind of drugs would
you give these cells and it turns out no
you don't give the cells any drugs you
just take the dish from the bad
environment put it back into a good
environment and the cells will innately
naturally come back to health again the
thinking is not that much in our control
the brain is operating as i said 95 from
the subconscious
but how did you actually then get
results in a relatively short space of
time well the the first thing how does a
subconscious learn and that's a very
critical thing uh the conscious mind can
learn from reading a book so you the
subconscious mind can read a self-help
book and you go wow that sounds really
great and then you find you read the
book but your life is still the same and
this turns out why and the answer is
because the subconscious mind is more of
a habit mind things that you repeat over
and over again
so the reality is if you can stay
conscious
be present
and when those negative thoughts come in
our head and psychologists tell us 70
percent of the time the thoughts that
are going through our head are negative
and redundant so the same negative
thoughts are going through if you could
stop those thoughts if you could hear
them as they come through like oh that's
not going to work or this will never
happen those kind of thoughts if you can
hear them and stop them consciously say
no
change the belief right there just give
the more positive thing
as you repeat this more frequently and
you keep repeating it the subconscious
mind begins to learn so as a habit if
you stay conscious and you have to work
at it
and here's why people say well how come
only five percent from conscious mind 95
for from subconscious because a
conscious mind can think into the future
and think into the past and solve
problems then think about it yourself
most of the time you're thinking about
something well if you're thinking you're
using the conscious mind well if you're
using the conscious mind for thinking
then who's running the show and the
answer is when you're not paying
attention and you're thinking about what
i'm going to do tomorrow your
subconscious is running
jesus told his followers
all the miracles that i can do you can
do them but even better than i can and
you don't believe it and that was the
whole damn thing in a nutshell
if you don't believe it you can't do it
and i said well where's belief come from
mind i say and then what have you been
programmed you can't do and i say then
you'll never be able to do it
and this is the problem and i and so we
talked about way number one you want to
change it hypnosis because that's the
original way things went in in the first
place and you're you know that what you
said was true
evenings just say i feel amazing i feel
amazing if you repeat that the mind will
will all of a sudden change how you feel
that's that's how it does it okay so i
say number one self hypnosis number two
after age seven you still learn how to
do new things that become habits like
you didn't learn how to drive a car
until until later then seven but once
you know how to drive a car remember the
first day you got in it was like oh my
god looking out the windows checking the
mirror watching the gauges keeping your
feet on the pedals just correctly you
know looking paying all these attentions
like
and i say today you've been driving for
a while you don't even think about that
you get in the car you put the key in
and now what are you thinking about well
what am i going to do when i get to the
store
you're not even thinking about driving
why it's a habit okay i say well how'd
you get that habit because you're older
than seven how'd you get it i said
repetition that's what makes a habit
practice you want to play an instrument
i'll hand you an instrument yeah you
didn't have any practice then you're not
going to be able to play it and i say oh
practice what is that repetition
that's the second way of subconscious
learns
repeating something over and over and
over again because that's called
habituation making a habit and i love it
the new age today thing is fake it till
you make it like what the hell is that i
say you're not happy yeah most of us
have trouble being happy and i say but
what if every day all day long and you
can remember you say i am happy in spite
of the fact that what the hell is going
on you just say i am happy
i am happy
i am happy i go why what's going on i
say repetition
and there'll be a point where you're
repeated to the degree that the
subconscious which learns by repetition
will put in i am happy i said then
what's the consequences of what's the
function of the mind take that program
and manifest it now that it's in there i
am happy i wake up one morning guess
what i don't have to say i'm happy it's
automatic
i'm already happy all day long my
program said that 95 is coming from that
habituation
you know repetition
of the exact thing you want not future
vision as if you have it now
we'll put it in a program so that's
first seven years hypnosis after seven
years uh repetition habituation is how
you change it
uh a sticky note people put that stuff
on a mirror or someplace and they go oh
yeah little sticky note and i go that is
not repetition that's a suggestion
a repetition is a practice you have to
repeat things that's you practice an
instrument you practice driving the car
you practice doing these things and then
it became real okay so the first two
things are
uh hypnosis
second thing is repetition
and thirdly the most
you know
effective
is called energy psychology i go what's
energy psychology
it's called super learning so what the
hell is super learning i go maybe you've
seen somebody read a book
by picking up a book and just moving
their finger down the page just like
that just as fast as that
and guess what
the subconscious mind the super computer
that it is has read every word just by
moving your finger down that has read
every word on that page and a person
using this super learning technique can
go into a bookstore open up a book in
five minutes later by thumbing through
each page turn the page turn the page
turn the page they can read a whole book
in five minutes that's super learning i
say if you can engage that function
you can also use super learning to
create
new programs not in days or weeks
but you can create a new program in
minutes
it's like
i go absolutely and it's so important
why because
there's an old phrase that's really
critical is called necessity as the
mother of invention
and i say what's happening we're facing
a mass extinction due to human behavior
that is compromising the web of life
humans are creating this through our
behavior our culture i say you want to
survive this this whole you know
extinction event
well then you have to create something
different
you have to change behavior i was a
scientist and as a scientist we don't
bring spirituality and mind into the
story it's all genes and cells and
molecules and all that
and my research
on on stem cells
revealed that while i was teaching in
medical school that genes control life
my research revealed that it was the
environment in which the cells lived
that control the cells it was outside
information coming into the cells
and i remember how specifically in a
moment of time
that i was working on trying to
understand the mechanics from a
molecular point of view how does an
environmental signal control biology
and i was working not on the genes i was
working on the skin of the cell the
membrane
and it was
it was so profound i it's hard for me to
even describe it i'm working on the
understanding how does information from
the environment control
biology and i had
looked at the membrane for years and i
wrote a new definition of the mechanism
of the membrane
and i wrote this definition this is in
1985. it was about 2 a.m
and i wrote down the membrane
is a liquid
crystal
semiconductor
with gates and channels
when i wrote that down there was a pause
and i said
i i just i i read something exactly like
that
and right next to my first computer
macintosh
was a book from a simple book of
understanding your microprocessor
and i opened it up and i said somewhere
and i open it right in the introduction
it said
a chip
is a crystal semiconductor with gates
and channels
and i thought oh what a coincidence they
have the same definition
and then in a couple of seconds i
started to say wait a minute
one for one the parts are exactly the
same i said oh oh my god
the membrane is a computer chip
and
on the surface of the cellar like keys
like on a typewriter
and and i started to realize oh my
goodness the environment
is typing
on the surface of the cell information
that went into the cell
and control the genetics and the
behavior and it was like oh oh this is
really exciting and i'm typing on my own
computer typing this information and
then i realized
i am outside of the computer
typing on the keyboard and the
information is coming up on the computer
then i said
oh my god
this keyboard on the surface of your
cells
has a number of keys
that represent a pin number a personal
identification number and no two of you
have the same keys on that each of us
have a different pin number to get into
our own cells it's our personal identity
and these are the keys and i realized oh
my god while we've been focusing on
these what are called receptors as the
source of identity i realized no
it's what's activating what's typing is
the identity and then it hit me and said
oh my god
my identity is not in the cell my
identity is a signal coming from the
environment typing on the keyboard and
then i said
oh
and the first thing that hit me was
i can't die
i'm not even in here
an instant the fear which all of us have
in our deepest bottom belief system
is a fear of my mortality
and when that moment of like i can't die
not as a devotional belief it had
nothing to do with that it was just a
mechanism i said oh my god i can't die
i'll tell you the same thing happened
with savages me
tears started rolling down my face and
this joy was an ache in my heart that
i've never experienced before i spent 40
years in my head that's how i became an
academician and a research scientist and
when this moment hit it was my heart
that blew open i refer to it as a heart
orgasm and
and that was the first time i
experienced my heart as a as an
essential part of my own conscious
existence
and what happened was i was overwhelmed
first with the fact that i was not
spiritual at 1 59 a.m
and at 2 a.m i was 100 spiritual when we
look at our lives and i tell you that 95
of your life is coming from the
subconscious program
this is not it's new on a scientific
awareness of how this mechanism works
but what's interesting is for 400 years
the knowledge that you could program
somebody and control their lives has
been available it was the jesuits who
400 years ago said
give me a child until it's seven
and i will show you the man
most people didn't understand what they
were saying and what it is is the first
seven years which we now know
biologically and scientifically is the
program period they knew that 400 years
ago and they said if i can get that
program in in the first seven years that
program will determine the life of that
individual i'll show you the man because
they will represent the program
now the really important part is since
every one of us has been programmed
the the big issue is so what were those
programs because if i ask you so what
what program did you get when you were
one year old
i have no idea i wasn't really there
in fact you were actually being
programmed even before you were born the
last trimester of pregnancy
you were being programmed and i go well
this is really critical issue because
the first thing i'm telling you is your
life is 95
programmed uh and most of that is is
really disempowering and of course the
first thing i would think is then what
are those programs so i could deal with
them so i want to make something very
easy for you so you don't have to
go and review your whole life and try to
figure out what the programs are save
you a lot of time
the fact is this you are playing the
program 95 of the day
meaning your life is a printout
of your program
so you don't have to go back in time to
review
that would just actually irritate the
system more because every time you
review those things that unsettled you
when when you were younger it just
reinforces that same pain that you had
earlier so going back uh and finding out
who did what to who
is
more than just a waste of time it
actually will set you back
a matter of fact there's an an old
phrase that people have heard and it
says don't kill the messenger over the
message
what that means is this don't go back
and blame all the people that did this
and that and that and that
that's irrelevant
who they are is irrelevant what's
relevant is what program did you walk
away with not who did the event but what
you learned so now i said okay
i've been programmed and i have no idea
what the program and i said then look at
your life and here's the simple
resolution
everything in your life that you like
and it comes to you
is because you have a program to support
that that's wonderful that means that's
great it's going to come to you because
that program is bringing it to you but
in contrast this is the one that's
important
anything you work hard to accomplish
anything you struggle over to make it
happen
anything you put a lot of effort in i
want this i'm going to work like crazy
i'm going to get this
my first question is
why are you working so hard
and the answer is very simple
anything you're struggling to try to
accomplish whether it's health or love
relationships whatever it is
if you're struggling it represents a
simple fact
your subconscious programming doesn't
support that conclusion
so the fact is what are my programs look
at your struggle
and wherever you're struggling
the struggle is not because the universe
won't provide for you the struggle is an
internal job the struggle is you're
trying to overcome
previous programming
that prevents you to go to that
destination so the wonderful part about
this understanding is you don't have to
to review your life you can look right
now at this one moment just look in your
head and say what are the things that i
keep trying to get and they they seem to
be elusive i can't get them they're
always out of reach i say
their their universe is not holding back
it's your own invisible subconscious
behavior when you're putting in a wish
and a desire put it in as if you already
have it
i am healthy
i am a good relationship person uh you
know i have a great job that what's that
i say it's like i already have it and
yet most people don't have it so they'll
say i want a great job i want a great
relationship i want to be healthy and i
go make a recording of those words we
just said that i want to be healthy
today right now
tuesday we're going to make a recording
i say now come back in one year and
let's push the button on that recording
and we come back a year later and it
says i want to be healthy i go it's a
whole year and you still want to be
honest still don't have it right
you can't say i am healthy
all you're emphasizing i have a desire
to be healthy i want to be healthy i
have a desire to be healthy i go
you can have that desire the rest of
your life you're not going to get
healthy you want to be healthy say i am
healthy but then you look and say yeah
but in reality i'm sick
and i go no no
the function of the mind is to take the
program and turn it into reality so if i
am sick but i put a program in i am
healthy the mind looks you know like
well wait a second the program is i am
healthy but the body is not healthy so
what's the function of the mind
create health in the body it doesn't
change the program
it changes the body and so the idea is
this every time we put a program in it
has to be as if you already have it in
spite of the fact you could be dying of
cancer i go i am healthy
it sounds kind of weird and i go don't
worry about it just put it on i am
healthy because once it is a program the
function of the mind is to manifest it
as reality
that's the part and so my little caveat
you brought it up i'm emphasizing it and
that was simply this that whatever
you're downloading you have to say it as
if you already have it because if you
put a future tense on it i will i want i
say
if you record that that means you will
always will you know want to have it you
know i will do this you won't get there
so i just wanted to bring that in
because if we're making a program then
you must make sure it says as if you
already have it in spite of the fact you
don't yo-ho-ho
oh wow
what a glorious day to be sailing on the
sea
i think i should be checking my bearings
at this point
north by northwest that's that's right
hank told me
take a left at the island then follow
north by northwest and until i go
towards the sunset
but it should be here somewhere
long island should be
somewhere but
it's not here
i think i better check my calculations
again
so i left fort morrisville 12
and going at eight knots by 12 35 we
should have been over here take the left
at the island and then we follow the
tangent of the cosine of 381 for eight
minutes to the right and then we should
be approaching toward
kong
[Music]
i'm lost at sea
what should i do now
i knew i should have trusted my feelings
when hank gave me directions it just
didn't even feel right and in today's
world we're told don't go by the
feelings
if i did i would have probably been
better off at this moment so when we
recognize we have to make a decision we
can do it in two fundamental ways first
do an assessment an analysis of step by
step what does this decision mean and
why should i choose it but when you get
to the end before you absolutely take
that information and make a decision
based on that ask your heart
and the reason why is this the heart
doesn't care about the individual steps
in the decision the heart only looks at
the conclusion either you get more
energy from this decision a good vibe a
feeling that this is right
or the heart will give you a feeling of
bad vibes less energy a feeling that
maybe this isn't the right answer
so the significance is really profound
because the heart just reads energy and
higher energy is more life less energy
is less life so
in making a decision yes it's acceptable
to do the analysis
but before you come to that final
decision
please
check in with your heart feel the
feelings if the feelings are good that
means go toward that direction
but if you feel questioned about it you
feel weaker about it doesn't just feel
right the heart is telling you right off
that that energy is not good for you and
you should use some other decision oh
wow
that's so wonderful what a wonderful way
to make a decision based on these
feelings and they can help us find the
direction that we need to go in and lead
us to a better life
[Music]
uh-oh
i guess that's not really working for me
at this moment
whoops
oh well
computer
and simulation
[Music]
how many times have i told you not to
leave me off at sea you know i can't
swim
meet me at the bridge you have some
splaining to do you want to change the
world we don't have to physically go out
and physically change the world first
first we have to change our belief about
the world our belief of who we are in
the world we're not victims but we've
been programmed to believe we're frail
vulnerable that we're victims of the
world the fact is no we are the most
powerful beings and entities on this
planet
we want to get out of the box
think out of the box and that will
change all of it everything you do in
your life you put out energy for
therefore start to review what you're
doing in your life because if you're
putting your energy into things you
cannot change in this world that is
exactly the same as writing a check and
just throwing away your money to the
outside because you get nothing back
from it so think about this very
interesting reality that you have this
energy checkbook and every time you use
energy you have to say is the use of
this energy
going to enhance my life or is it just
wasted energy am i getting involved in a
in a political argument with people
where i'm going to use up all my energy
and will i have changed the world no
am i going to use up all my energy to
try to convince other people to change
their life or change their way of living
to make them even healthier
and they're not ready to do that i'd be
wasting my energy
so here's an interesting thought
if i gave you an energy checkbook and
asked you to write a check every time
you had to have a thought you would have
to then ask yourself is is this thought
going to enhance my life or is this
thought going to take away from my life
and then when you start to realize that
you start to direct your actions where
you put your energy into things that
enhance your life and give you an
opportunity to survive and to go beyond
survival and really into thriving
so the point is this we are facing some
rough times the more thoughts you put
into the negative aspect the more
thoughts you put into the fear uh not
only are you just wasting your energy
but as in the biology belief these
negative thoughts these negative
stresses actually impair your immune
system and bring on disease itself you
have a very close friend you know your
friend's behavior and you happen to know
your friend's parent and at some point
you see that your friend shares the same
behavior as their parent so you you know
you casually volunteer you go you know
bill you're just like your dad and
that's when you have to back away from
bill
because bill's the first guy that says
how can you compare me to my dad and
everyone laughs because they're familiar
but i say no there's two very profound
points from that one story and profound
point number one
everybody else can see that bill behaves
like his dad he got his programming from
his dad it's only bill who doesn't see
it
and profound point number two we're all
bill
because all of us got programming and
all of us operate with these programs
and we don't even see we're doing that
we even when told we're doing it we'll
deny that we do these behaviors because
we don't even see what we're doing
that's why it's called subconscious
below conscious when i first started
talking about it it was from an academic
conscious point of view this is what i
learned but my subconscious programs are
still exactly the same so well i had
this wonderful knowledge my life still
wasn't anything i wanted to to brag
about it because it wasn't and and as
you know that old game well who would
you like to be and i could think of
anybody i'd rather be than me and yet
when i started to apply the new science
and rewrite the subconscious so it
supported me rather than the programs of
limitation or disempowerment that we get
from our parents and our community as
children which almost all of us get when
i put in the new programs all of a
sudden i started to find my goodness my
life completely turned around uh all
wonderful things started happening in my
life i was healthier i've been to a
doctor in 20 years i i don't need that i
don't take any of their drugs why
because
most of the illness is just from the
stress of not living in harmony and when
you learn to to get rid of the limiting
programs that we got as children and put
in programs that support you guess what
then all of a sudden the place turns
into heaven
and it's interesting people i tell
people will you create your own life and
then they look around and go i don't
want responsibility for this but i say
well you didn't know you were creating
with these unconscious beliefs and and
yet then i tell people especially people
that have fallen in love and people have
fallen head over heels in love i said go
back to that time when you first fell in
love
let me ask you a question were you
healthy and oh yeah i was i was healthy
as anything i said you have energy oh i
had so much energy made love for days in
a row without even eating and i go yeah
and i go uh and how was life for you it
was so exciting i couldn't wait for the
next day so i said in this little period
that you you know that i refer to as a
honeymoon i say
wasn't life like heaven on earth and
they go well yeah and i go you know that
was not
an accident that was an actual creation
and you say but what was different that
made life uh
so heaven on earth during love and the
answer is because you become very
self-conscious of yourself you don't
rely on the habits
the day before you meet this person
you're going to go on a date i say
especially to women i said how long did
it take you get dressed and say well i
was 15 minutes and i was out of the
house and i say now tonight you're going
to go on a date with this person who has
just rocked your world and i said how
long does it take you to get dressed
it's like my god it may take an hour or
two and i say
yesterday 15 minutes today an hour or
two what's the difference yesterday i
got dressed by habit because i get
dressed every day but tonight i am
looking in the mirror meaning i am
self-conscious i am making sure that i
represent myself to be the fully the
best individual i can be and when both
parties are not relying on the habit and
both of them are saying i'm creating the
best i can be they're living in the
moment of the now they're being very
mindful they're being very present and
guess what
heaven on earth is created many people
may think well hold on a second so i can
take five minutes and i can totally
change my life and that's all i need and
i think well that that's a really a
wonderful possibility
but the probability is this are you
going to hit the right statement
that is the one that you need to change
your life okay uh let's say someone's
overweight
and they say in their mind i i am you
know a weight a number they like i am
125 pounds and you're not
uh and i say
uh so i want to change my weight and i
put a program in i'm going to lose
weight
and i go but well wait
that extra poundage uh that might be due
to protection like what do you mean
if i as an as a young person was abused
then the consciousness is if i'm a heavy
person they won't bother me anymore
and so the weight isn't due to just
eating food the weight would
move to
i'm safer
of being heavy than i am i say well if
you want to change your weight you can
talk about the weight all you want but
until you adjust the problem from the
the fear uh you know that i'm going to
be abused that's where the problem came
from it didn't come from eating food
over here so i said yeah well you can
change beliefs uh sometimes i like to
give a visual a matter of fact i
visualize a big spider web which has
like circles and then
lines coming out you know like a web
okay
and so there are links as you go around
there's also anchors where the web is
anchored at a couple of places and i go
each belief is like a link
in that spider web and you can do one
link and another link and another link
that really changes buyer web but if you
do a belief that is an anchor
and you change the anchor belief and
that anchor lets go
the web will collapse that's powerful
and the point is this
sometimes a belief statement knocks out
a link
but when you really hit it just right
you knock out a support
and when you knock out a major support
the whole web
collapses instead of just a link at a
time which could take it down but it's
much harder
in our mind we start to realize that
we're concerned we're afraid we don't
have enough i'm not safe i'm not secure
and i say oh these thoughts i was
talking about the thoughts in your mind
go in and control your biology your
genetics your physiology and your health
and i go yes this is really true
i say well how can i tell you what your
thoughts are in a sense that can i read
your thoughts and i say yes you know i
could put wires on your head and it's
called
electroencephalograph and i could read
your brain activity and i go oh great i
can see this brain activity
i want to tell you something that's
profoundly important
we were
programmed to believe that our thoughts
are contained in our head that if i have
a thought it's just for me not for
anybody else it's inside and it's
working through me
and now i want to tell you about a new
technology it's not electro
encephalograph it's called magneto
encephalograph i say what's unique about
that i say read your brain i say yeah
but so does eeg i say yeah but eeg you
put the wires on the head and you get
the electrical activity conducted
through the skin from the brain and
that's what i'm reading and i said
what's different about emig
the probe is out here
and i said what does that mean
your thoughts are not contained in your
head
your thoughts are broadcast to the field
just like a radio broadcast
i said well what if i as an individual
have a thought that says
let's have peace in the world
and i broadcast out there in the street
and i say let's have peace and i look
around it's like
where's the peace i don't see the peace
and here's what the relevance is
each of us is broadcasting
if you get enough people
to have the same thought
that broadcast is amplified
each of us has a small power
but if you put a thousand people the
same thought ten thousand a hundred
thousand people with the same thought
you are broadcasting a most powerful
thought not just in your body but out in
the field i say your energy's in the
field the thought is in the field and
you go well what does that mean and then
i'll give you this most wonderful quote
i used it the other day in a lecture
from albert einstein
and the quote is so important here's the
quote
the field
so definite definition the field is the
invisible energy right now you're in a
field there's cell phone
for
television
radio broadcast all kinds of information
coming across but guess what each one of
you is a broadcast in that field
the quote
the field
is the sole
governing agency of the particle
particle is the material realm
so what was einstein saying it's the
energy in the field that shapes the
physical experience of our lives and if
enough of us collectively have an energy
that's coherent and strong and we
broadcast a belief
we change the world
i just want you to recognize as much as
i wanted peace in the world if not
enough people are out there saying let's
have peace in the world there is no
peace
if i want to say let's have a war how
can you have a war you have to have
enough people convinced
that the war is going to benefit them so
that their broadcast say yes let's have
a war because i and my colleagues we're
all going to have a better result from
that
and the reality is this
the only things that change on this
planet collectively or when we
collectively share
thoughts
and yoga
when you're in your postures when you're
in your process your mind is sharing a
thought not just in your head
but all around you
so the whole idea about this is we have
to recognize
we are collectively
creating reality with our thoughts
and if we want to change reality it can
change instantly
the moment we become coherent the moment
we collectively are on the same platform
of thinking
you get enough people to say peace there
will be peace instantly in this world
but we've been programmed by other
people to
give them the power to tell us what we
need
and assad fiji has been telling us so
importantly what we need is not what
they tell us what we need is what we
know
and i really hope that you understand
this because when you have your thoughts
recognized it's not contained in your
head your thoughts out in the field
and that thought the field is the soul
governing agency of matter
and therefore
what this world is looking for at this
moment is an evolution
it's not an evolution of our biology our
biology has already evolved
it's an evolution of our consciousness
when we collectively as a population say
enough is enough
it will end we all have approximately 50
trillion cells in our body and these
cells are all self-sufficient they have
their own memory they have their immune
immune system and in fact you're also
going to say that for 2.75 billion years
there was only one celled organisms
alive on the planet yeah
and and the nature is
as the single cell evolved to be the
most intelligent and could be it ran
into a physical limitation because
intelligence is physically tied up with
the membrane or skin of the cell you can
only have so much membrane
so evolution apparently stopped it was
like two and a half billion years just a
single cell organism then it said well
how can you have more evolution the
answer is cells decided to come together
in community because when cells come
into community they share awareness so
there's more awareness with ten cells
than there is with one cell and there's
more awareness with a million or a
billion or a trillion so when you look
at a human being while we see ourselves
as single entities the truth is we are
made out of 50 trillion amoeba
amoeba-like cells and so our body is
this giant community
and what makes it very exciting as you
mentioned is well in my own work with
cloning cells i can take a cell out of
your body and it can live outside of you
why it has its own intelligence it has
essentially every function in your body
is present in a cell so my
seven-year-old vision manifests to be
true when i got older to realize cells
are miniature people and then you say
well what about happens in the human
body and i go this is where the issue
comes in is because you have 50 trillion
cells living in community but your mind
is the government
when a government works in harmony with
the people
then the people thrive and the community
is is in good health and grows but when
a government is not really supportive or
not working in in harmony with a
community then the government could
cause the
the nature of that community to fall
apart and even lead to to to the end of
the community well that's what we're
finding out our mind is the government
and when we entertain harmony and and
the right living and balanced with
nature and with each other then we
provide our 50 trillion cells with very
life supporting information and
chemistry so harmony means
giving the body
good food yes not being stressed out
absolutely living in a in a happy
environment yes
basically it says uh it's as i said when
i had my petri dish of cells if i put it
from a healthy environment to a bad
environment the cells got sick but you
didn't have to give them drugs
but all you did is take the the dish
from the bad environment and put it in a
good environment and the joke which i
like to tell people is
well this happens in a plastic petri
dish but guess what
we are skin covered petri dishes
underneath our skin
is 50 trillion cells living in a dish
and the culture medium is the blood and
so when i change the culture medium to
plastic dish i change the fate of the
cells and i say well then what controls
the culture medium my blood the
chemistry and the answer is
my thoughts influence my brain and the
brain releases chemistry that matches my
thoughts so when i'm in stress or i'm
afraid of the world i release different
chemistry into the blood than if i open
up my eyes and i find myself in love i
release completely different chemistry
and it's like well
all i have to ask an individual is how
do you feel when you're in total love or
how do you feel when you're in fear and
answers well i feel totally different i
guess what
all the cells are bathed in that
chemistry and so the the feeling of love
produces totally different chemistry in
the blood chemistry that supports growth
and healing of the body and supports the
immune system and in contrast
when we perceive reasons to be afraid
and we release stress hormones into our
body
we actually shut off the growth
mechanisms and the immune system to
serve to save the energy
why because if you believe you're going
to have to run from that lion
you want all the energy available to run
from a line so when a person is in
stress
they allocate their energy reserves for
fight or flight
but take it at the expense of the health
of the system the immune part of the
system and so the more stress you're
under the more bad chemistry in a sense
of not supporting you you that you
experience uh and and it's a very
important point
in our evolution stress or fear was not
the main stay of life the mainstay of
life was to be happy and live in the
harmony of the environment
every now and then a saber-toothed tiger
would come okay now it's time to be
stressed out now it's time to run but
the point is once you escape from the
saber-tooth tiger in the old days then
it's like oh back to health and harmony
and i say what about today's world
today's world is 24 7 run from the tiger
and this is not biologically sustainable
because uh the chemistry of protection
uh contrasts with the chemistry of
growth being a biologist i want to talk
about a different aspect of service but
it's the same thing because my dear
friend saviji was talking about service
and how we can influence the world
around us i want to give you an
interesting biological insight about
your own personal consequence of being
in service
and basically
it has to deal with the dna in your
cells i say what does that mean i say
well
the dna is the genetic code
i say and every time the cell divides
you have to copy that code
and so if i can try to make an image
with my hand here imagine my arm is the
dna
and i say it's time to copy it
there's a protein so let's say the
microphone okay thank you
that my arm my hand is the copying
device it's like a train on a railroad
track
as the train moves down the dna it
leaves behind a copy of the dna it just
rode over
i say well that's really cool except
guess what when the train gets to the
end of the dna
it can't copy
the part where the train is sitting on
it so it copied everything all the way
up to here but can't copy this piece so
when i copy it the new piece is shorter
than the original piece
and so every time you copy every time
the cell divides the dna gets a little
shorter than it did before
and i say well why is this relevant
because if you make a shorter piece of
dna when you copy it then every time
you're copying it you're interfering
with the genetic code
so it's like well nature would say oh my
god if every time the cell divides
pretty soon i'll chop that dna up and
i'll have a problem
but nature of course being
quite intelligent adds a piece of dna at
the end that it's not the gene it's just
an extension it's called a telomere you
may have heard the word telomere and i
say what is it it's an extra railroad
track but it's not the genes and i say
why is it relevant because every time i
copy it i lose a piece of the telomere
but i didn't cut into the genes and i
say well what's aging all about
and here's what we now know aging
depression and disease
result when you copy the dna so many
times that you run out of that track of
telomere and the next time you copy
you're cutting off the gene which
interferes with your biology
so originally it was thought oh the
telomeres have a fixed length and every
time it divides you lose a piece of the
length and the scientists back in the
60s leonard hey flick calculated how
many times can a cell divide before it
runs out of telomere and it came out oh
it was about 50 to 60 cell divisions i
say well why is that relevant because
our stem cells which keep us alive
when they keep dividing what happens
after your stem cells went through 50
cell divisions now your stem cells won't
work anymore and now you can't replace
your cells in your body and that's when
they said oh humans have a given
lifetime you know 90
100 years at max
and that's your lifetime because that's
when you run out of telomeres
that was very depressing
because it says oh my god if i'm under
stress i actually cut the telomeres even
faster the more stress you're under the
more they disappears now
and it was because of again a woman
scientist because they always come up
with the neat stuff that the men are not
looking at
uh a woman scientists found there was an
enzyme
an enzyme called telomerase
telo
enzyme telomerase and i say what's that
enzyme it adds the length of the
telomere so as the cells are dividing if
you can activate this enzyme
it will extend the telomeres so the
cells have a relatively unlimited
lifespan
and so the relevance is the belief that
we only live 100 years is mainly a
consequence of not being able to
continue to extend the telomeres in a
normal person
so they start to find out well what
influences the telomere
well the biggest thing is lack of love
if you don't if you have a lack of love
the feedback will shut off the
telomerase enzyme
if
you have stress in your life
stress shuts off the enzyme
if you have no gratitude
or
appreciation of life it shuts off the
enzyme why well if you don't like life
then why give you an extra life that's
the enzyme is just responding
but now it comes down to the opposites
of those
love
and self-love which is most critical
is one of the the big drivers of
telomerase
gratitude
and joy of being in this world enhances
the enzyme why if you love the world you
want more and the cells will give you
more
but now and it's a beautiful question
the most important contributor to
telomerase activity
is service
that you are doing something on this
planet you have a mission to do
something and that your nervous system
is telling yourselves i'm not ready to
go i have a job to do
and caregivers for example live an
extraordinarily longer healthier life
than other people why a caregiver's
mentality is i have to service and help
these people and therefore i cannot
leave yet and i have to be healthy
the feedback from the nervous system to
the cells activates telomerase so the
simple line is this
if we have a mission
and we have something to do on this
planet
you will activate telomerase service is
one of the primary things so it says if
you're just meandering through the earth
nice you're going to end around 90.
but if you're in service to the world
you can extend your life and right now
biologists somewhat agree that our
minimum
life span is a hundred and forty years
medical science has revealed that from
one-third to two-thirds which is
significant of all healing whether it's
drug-related or surgery or whatever
healing process
the healing didn't come about from the
process the healing came about because
the person believed the process was
going to heal them so if i give you this
brand new drug and it's purple colored
because that makes it really special you
know and it's funny because there is a
drug a purple drug and they said it's
purple and everybody's like oh wow
that's got to be special but people
believe that the drug holds this effect
and you give the person this drug
and all of a sudden they heal themselves
and they say yeah the drug did it and
then you tell them later but it was just
a sugar pill
that that healing didn't come from the
drug it came from the belief in the drug
so
the belief in healing
the mind again isn't it yeah it's again
the power of belief in this case it's a
very positive belief that this procedure
drug or whatever is going to heal me but
what people haven't talked about because
everyone knows about the placebo effect
is that
the placebo effect i don't know is based
on a positive thinking
what is the consequence of negative
thinking ah well science has a term for
it but it hasn't really come out in the
public it's called the nocebo effect and
the nocebo effect has been revealed by
science that a negative thought can not
only make you ill
but a negative thought could also kill
you you can be scared to death in us in
a real sense okay
and and why is that important because it
turns out it's not just the positive
thought of placebo that's influential
the negative thought works the same way
with the same power but in the opposite
direction so basically it's not placebo
no sibo
it comes down simply this it's the power
of thought
and a positive thought will move you in
a healing direction and a negative
thought will move you into an illness
direction
but before i get off that topic i don't
want people to go out there in the
audience and go oh oh one of those
positive thinking kind of guys it's like
it's more than just positive thinking
it's a commitment and an intention of
positive thinking it also really needs
the support of your subconscious belief
because if your subconscious belief is
going oh that new age weirdos stuff
that's what your subconscious is
programmed to believe and yet your
conscious mind is the one that says i
will think positive thoughts and i go
back to the data only five percent of
your life is coming from the conscious
mind so if you're only entertaining a
positive thought with your conscious
mind you're only contributing five
percent of that to your life 95 percent
of your life is still coming from the
subconscious and if the subconscious
doesn't hold those beliefs
then you're actually fighting yourself
and not likely to realize the expression
of a positive thought you have to wake
up to the reality folks that you're all
a bunch of weak and vulnerable people
when it comes to what's outside there
the sky is literally falling reports
from australia have come in that
everybody that walked outside their
survival shelter was literally crushed
by the sky as it came down upon them the
once beautiful and green hills of the
countryside have become a barren
wasteland not to mention a band of
unruly sorcerers and bewitched the land
there are even reports of animals taking
up arms walking on two legs be afraid
everyone this is something we could
never anticipate it is my job to keep
you informed of all the latest horrible
things going on out there i'm just
trying to protect you
i can't take any more of this i can't i
can't watch this anymore
no more water
no more food
how am i going to survive in here
but i can't go out there
i can't survive in here
i can't survive out there
what am i gonna do
meet bruce lipton
portrait of a man paralyzed by fear
the lowly cellular biologist has been
hiding away in his survival shelter for
more days than he can count
and the apparent terror that reigns
outside the doors of his rusty
presents a limitless degree of terror in
his mind
however
there is one problem that takes center
stage on this inauspicious day
bruce has run out of food and water
the question of how to survive
in a state of chronic protection
lingers ever so greatly
what you are about to witness is a
strange sort of mortal combat between a
man
and his beliefs
in the twilight zone
you are entering a new reality of mind
unlock your potential with the key of
imagination
a realm of ever-changing perceptions
a world of quantum physics
beliefs and miracles you have just
crossed over
into the twilight zone
i've got no more water
and i've got no more food
i can't survive by staying in protection
in order to survive i have to go out
because i can grow on the outside
and i can't go out there
because there's so many scary things out
there that can threaten my life but
wait a minute
it was in quantum physics
yes quantum physics the most valid
science on this
planet ah
here it is
consciousness is creating our life
experiences
wow
i have to have a different consciousness
i can't be afraid because the stress
shuts off my immune system
and the stress shuts down my growth and
maintenance of my body i have to change
that consciousness i can't be in fear
i have to recognize how powerful i am
i am a co-creator of the world
i am strong i am healthy i have to
maintain this as a way of life a belief
system before i go out there
but now that i'm aware
i no longer fear
going out there
[Music]
the world can often present us with a
frightening reality but sometimes the
fear we experience only exists in our
minds and now for bruce
fear only exists
in the twilight zone what you we would
see from a new understanding of
evolution which is a great extension
beyond the darwinian belief belief which
is quite limiting okay and quite
troublesome in fact uh because just
think about what the principle darwinian
belief is uh that evolution is based on
a struggle for survival with a
competition for fitness so that says oh
my god then our world is we're all out
there in a dog-eat-dog
rat race trying to survive because if
you stop running the person behind you
is going to run over you so if that's
your way of life then every day by
definition you are living in a stress
hormone
body because of all the fears that we
that we have and yet evolution says no
evolution is based on community and
cooperation a body has 50 trillion
citizens they live in harmony with each
other and it turns out that
every human being we're beginning to
find out is like a cell
in a larger community called humanity so
in biological terms the organism that's
evolving on the planet is not the human
being we already did that the organism
that's evolving is the super organism
called human civilization
and right now
humans are fighting each other and
killing each other and if i say well
what would that look like inside the
body if the cells fight each other and
kill each other and i say oh well that's
called autoimmune disease
self-destruction
and and autoimmune disease can kill you
from the inside that's on the increase
isn't it oh absolutely because the
because our biological lives are
complements to the environment the more
stress and more
violence on the outside the more that's
taken inside in biology and converted to
uh disruption and disharmony of your own
cellular internal community if you can
create a honeymoon for yourself while
you're in love and everyone started to
create a honeymoon for themselves then
all of a sudden the concept of war and
violence would disappear because if
everybody's in love and everybody's in
harmony and everybody's so excited by
being here
then the competition and violence that
we live by because of today's beliefs
would disappear so as you understand the
terms quantum physics and quantum
mechanics or newtonian physics and
newtonian mechanics what you see is that
physics and mechanics are synonyms so
physics
really means the mechanisms by which the
universe operates and the new physics
quantum physics was something that i
really wasn't into nor were any of my
colleagues in the medical school we were
all trained in newtonian physics and the
difference between the two is very
profound newtonian physics says the
world that we live in the universe we
live in is a machine made out of
mechanical parts if you want to
understand how it works take it apart
study the pieces change the pieces
change the operation that's the basis of
medicine we look at a human body it's a
machine made out of physical parts when
it's not working right change the parts
by buying chemicals and drugs
and that's the way that conventional
medicine operates
when i started to read the quantum
physics i realized oh my goodness
the whole foundation of the universe is
not based on a mechanical physical
universe it's based on the invisible
energy called the field so let's say if
i hold a magnet right here in front of
you you can see the magnet but what you
can't see is the invisible magnetic
field and so what it says is well we are
physical things in our world like
physical bodies we're immersed in fields
electro
magnetic fields magnetic fields itself
all kinds of fields like telephone cell
phone fields television fields radio
fields whole ranges
what is the difference between the
newtonian physics and the quantum
physics is this newtonian physics focus
on the particles quantum physics says
you won't understand why the particles
take this shape then you have to
understand the field it's the field that
controls biology it's the invisible
forces there's a great quote by albert
einstein and it's simple it goes
the field
is the sole
governing agency of the particle
in other words in the world of invisible
things fields and particles matter
it's the field that gives shape to the
matter and this is the basis of quantum
physics this becomes relevant it says
okay here's the physical particles of my
body why are they in a healthy state or
why could they be in a sixth state
that's the physical expression and the
answer is well to understand that don't
look at the body you have to understand
the invisible forces in the field uh it
is it's fun because if you think about
when when of course when you were young
at some point you must have had like
iron filings and sprinkled it around a
magnet and all of a sudden you saw the
iron filings form that pattern of the
magnetic field
well quantum physics
would look at this pattern
and try to explain how come all the iron
filings fell in this pattern without
recognizing that the field exists in
other words can you explain why the iron
filings have the shape if you don't
recognize the magnetic field the answer
is absolutely not
what's the nature of it
the body and its cells are like iron
filings medicine is trying to understand
the nature of the body by looking at the
iron filings and quantum physics says if
you don't understand that invisible
field you cannot understand what's
happening in the body everybody's mind
is like a tuning fork because actually
you can read brain activity from outside
your head with a new thing called
magnetoencephalograph
most people are familiar
electroencephalogram put wires on your
head and read your brain function
the new one magnetoencephalograph they
put a probe out here and they can read
your brain function from outside well
it's a very important point it says well
if you're reading my brain function from
outside then what am i doing i must be
broadcasting my brain function so all of
us are like tuning forks but if we're
all out of tune
then there's a tendency for even a
tuning fork that tries to stay in tune
will be pushed out of tune by something
we call entrainment and the issue is
how can you survive in this world the
answer is you must essentially detach
yourself from this field around you not
be taken in by the stories not be
buy into the fear not to buy into the
threats on our existence to start to
recognize look we are creating these
lives if you buy other people's creation
then you manifest what they're creating
if you want what you want then you have
to not get engaged and the more
conscious you become
the less you are affected by the outside
fields and so this rising consciousness
that we're seeing is the evolution of
humanity to rise above the noise of the
background and recognize you're the
creator we also bought this and it's not
true
that there's somebody in the
subconscious meaning
if my conscience finds my subconscious
engaging some behavior that's not
supporting it and my conscience is
talking to myself and my conscience
saying bruce scott that was stupid you
could do better than that and you're
having this inner dialogue and you're
talking yourself and being very upset
about the fact that your behavior seems
to be out of control
who are you talking to
and i love this because the reality is
we're thinking we're talking to
ourselves and that's going to fix
something and what's it going to fix
well the program's in that subconscious
and here's where the problem lies
subconscious is a tape player there's
nobody in there
the the the same exact truth holes in
this case get a tape player put a
cassette tape in it push play the
program's running and you don't like the
programming so here's what i want you to
do
go up and talk to the tape player go up
and talk to it suggest that it changed
the program even tell it what you wanted
to play do you do all this and then you
realize the program still plays it
doesn't change and then you get more
upset
with yourself why because you've asked
this program to change it's not changing
yet then you get mad at yourself you
start yelling at yourself and now you're
berating yourself because you can't
control the tape
then that doesn't work and then of
course the last step you have to bring
god in because obviously you tried a
change your life and it didn't work so
only god has to come in here now and
change the tape and and the joke is
how much talking to a tape player does
it take before the tape changes the
answer is you can talk to your blue in
the face and it will not change it's not
that you can't change the tape
but you have to learn how to push the
record button
and then you can record new programs in
the subconscious but our old belief
system like conventional psychology
let's go over and find out why my life
is this way oh yeah my mom did this to
me and my dad did this and my friends
did this and now i make a whole list of
all the reasons why my life is this way
i'm very clear my conscious mind's got
oh god i could play that movie i can see
it and the question is now that you're
aware did it change the tape player the
answer is no
and that's why people get so upset they
they go through all of this psychology
counseling and stuff they know all the
reasons they still have the same life so
the issue is you want to make change
then you have to learn how to engage the
tape player in a record mode and not
just talk to it
time
you in here
[Music]
hello
doc yeah it's marty where are you
oh
okay yeah yeah i'll be right there
[Music]
doc
doc
doc where are you
doc let me in it's pouring rain out here
just wait just wait two more seconds huh
[Music]
oh
oh
no
oh
marty
marty marty we gotta get back to the
future doc what what happened to the
delorean well i couldn't keep up with
the payments during the pandemic but hey
this is a good baby
[Music]
all right all right
marty marty we have to go back to the
future right now doc
the future seems very uncertain i don't
think we should be going to the future
right now you're not thinking fourth
dimensionally get in the car i'll
explain it to you when we get there all
right
[Music]
[Music]
whoa
doc
where are we when are we
marty just look at the inborn monitor
down there and what you can see is we
are in between time we're moving from an
old civilization and we're moving
through time into the future of a new
civilization
wow this looks pretty chaotic and random
is that normal well actually it's not
random and you're right it is chaotic
because chaotic has pattern even though
you can't see it and if you want to know
what the pattern is look
the old civilization is coming down and
as it's coming down the pieces are
forming a new civilization that is
rising up and we are now in the middle
so it's not random so this is all just a
big illusion well it is an illusion
because once you think the world is made
out of matter and energy that's a false
understanding but now quantum physics
revealed there is no separation of
matter and energy atoms which make up
matter are energy so everything is an
illusion reality is an illusion albeit a
persistent one
so you're telling me that the future
changes depending on the field that we
have intentions for well absolutely the
reason is this because as the planet
moves through the solar system and the
universe the energy surrounding this
planet changes that's the field and when
the field changes the matter changes so
we are in a process of evolution moving
from an old structure into a new
sustainable world
to understand what i'm talking about
marty look at the inboard monitor there
i can show you about the science called
cymatics that's the science of how
vibration and energy and field shapes
matter
as you can see how it works you sprinkle
particles on a metal plate and then when
you play a vibration and energy field
through that plate the vibration causes
the particles to jump around and form a
pattern but when you change the
vibration the old pattern falls apart
and simultaneously a new pattern is
emerging this is exactly where we are
today and planet earth
wow doc that is sick
sick marty i don't know what you kids
are talking about everything is sick no
we're moving into the future where
everything is health and harmony and
love hold on marty
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you're special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want some amazing joe dispenza
motivation check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there self-love is no longer about
pleasure or having a car it's something
that you're cultivating within you so
then imagine we have research to show
and this is such a this is such a
duality